[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui ma parole d'oxfam si melissa maulin
dupuis non je ne suis pas en vacances
cette semaine
j'avais juste besoin de réconfort donc
en ayant ma couverture pendleton ou même
en ayant ma petite ans avec bébé yoda et
toutes mes beaux symboles de médias
sociaux que j'aime tellement j'ai voulu
vous approché pour faire une chronique
beaucoup plus légères qu'à l'habitude
je veux parler ni de spectacle où le
secteur autochtone pourquoi il est dans
ce qui est en train de faire des vagues
sur les médias les médias sociaux on
commence à reconnaître l'apport
important des créateurs de contenu
autochtone sur un média sociaux que tik
tok tok est souvent vu comme le média
social que les gens utilisent pour faire
des danses ou recréer des danses à
d'ailleurs été identique comme cela ce
média social qui appartient plutôt à la
génération z mais de plus en plus la
génération x
les millénium et même les boumeurs
commencent à s'approprier ce média
social parce qu'elle est bien c'est la
pandémie
il est accessible il est extrêmement
agréable très facile d'utilisation
permet de faire des récits des histoires
et n'importe qui peut devenir virale du
jour au lendemain avec une bonne
histoire un bon contenu donc les
premières nations qui sont des conteurs
d'histoires par excellence ont pris
d'assaut ce média social
ils se sont appropriés justement tout la
possibilité toute la capacité qu'ils ont
de raconter leur histoire de parler de
leur culture et de la partager avec le
monde de façon positive et de façon
intéressante faut pas oublier que par le
passé pourquoi on était absent dans les
grands médias c'est qu'on a souvent
précieux qui choisissez le contenu donc
avec les médias sociaux ne put un petit
peu je dirais débouchés la venue des
premières nations
on a pu voir par exemple moi je sais que
facebook a permis la montée de haydn
moment par exemple on est plus organisé
un groupe en depuis manifesté on a pu se
faire entendre notre message
comme on n'avait jamais vu auparavant
dans les grands médias ensuite c'est à g
instagram qui permettait aux artisans de
vendre leurs boucles d'oreilles par
exemple
ou leur artisanat d'une manière que l'on
pouvait pas faire si on n'allait pas
dans les power et bien victor lui ouvert
une autre voie permettre de faire des
petits des petits vidéos de présenter
des films qui parlent de la culture et
pour avoir exploré énormément ça fait
une vidéo sont superbes femmes parce que
on peut
j'en dis - dans sa langue
comment on peut compter de 1 à 5 je
pense à une les amis xavier watson qui a
justement un stock et que je vois son
stock il soit on va lancer et les
légions de plusieurs maisons utilise
justement 7 7 - dépend pour partager
leur langue leur culture mais j'ai vu
aussi des vidéos que je ne m'attendais
jamais à voir et que j'étais tellement
contente ce n'est pas un documentaire
mais c'était quand même un documentaire
puisque par exemple j'ai vu comment ils
fabriquaient de la crème glacée inoke
c'est la graisse animale mélangés avec
des canneberges et j'ai appris quelque
chose de plus en regardant ces vidéos là
parce que je ne le savais pas mais pour
qu'elle soit digestive et facile moi je
voudrais processus dans le corps il faut
faire des bulles avec avant de les gérer
donc j'avais vraiment l'impression de
regarder un document pas fait par un
entrepôt l'oeil jeudi au regard des les
inuit vont maintenant bon j'ai la crème
glacée mais c'était vraiment quelqu'un
chez eux qui nous invitaient qui nous
montrer comment elle se faisait cette
traversée comment on la mange et dont
j'avais l'impression d'aller en visite
chez quelqu'un et ça pour moi sa mort
raviver le sentiment de communauté qui
me manque beaucoup en ce moment
puisqu'on est loin les uns des autres
puisque on se garde en sécurité à cause
du vide et c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai
tellement eu le goût de me perdre dans
le titre autochtone parce que ce
sentiment de pouvoir évacuer tout ce qui
est négatif que ce soit le racisme
systémique le fait que certaines
personnes ont essayé de voler des doses
de vaccin ou communauté autochtone les
femmes assassinées super u tout c'est un
jeu venant limited ce qui est un peu la
relation toxique avec le canada et bien
j'ai pu en fait
ok on prend un pause et je peux voir ce
que j'ai envie de voir des cultures
autochtones au canada ça
le côté rich le côté vivant le côté qui
se partage équitable précis non
seulement par les communautés
autochtones mais aussi par les
communautés allochtone parce que ces
vidéos ne sont pas uniquement vu par nos
communes donc je vous invite à vous
taire dans les médias sociaux
autochtones parce qu'au public et ses
soins par les médias sociaux par les
médias alternatifs qu'on a pu faire
entendre nos voix est de plus en plus
bien comment ça prend une plateforme qui
est équivalente à celle des nouvelles
allochtone par exemple parce que l'autre
fois c'est les médias sociaux nous ont
permis de dépasser d'aller plus loin que
ce que les médias traditionnels nous
laissait on a quand même eu la
télévision on a quand même eu la radio
qui étaient des outils justement deux
communautés pour savoir qu'est ce qui se
passe et comment ça allait le mariage de
l'autre le baptême de le bingo keller
qui allait avoir lieu
donc ce sentiment communauté là mais
j'ai pu leur vie à travers tout ça c'est
une bonne manière de le faire en me
parlant que la pandémie se calmer en
vain pendant qu'on puisse retourner
justement n'allait pas avoir dans les
communautés et ceux visités et je pense
que ça peut attiser l'intérêt des autres
communautés 20 les cultures autochtones
et se rendent compte à quel point ils
ont ignoré
ne serait ce qu un pourcentage était
même moi si j'ai des six mois un team
qui en fait ma vie je découvre de
nouvelles choses me dit on apprendra on
n'arrêtera jamais d'apprendre
donc n'hésitez pas à partager ses vidéos
il n'était pas non plus un rixe le rite
stocks
instagram facebook autochtone et surtout
mes chroniques sont maintenant rendues
disponibles sous forme de podcast on
peut les trouver sur itunes les podcasts
daito mais aussi spotify et plusieurs
autre forme de podcasts ont fait
partager pour les envoyer à vos amis qui
se posent des questions sur les enjeux
autochtones et n'hésitez pas non plus à
nous envoyer des questions
c'est une belle semaine